ils sont encore une vingtaine au sort
incertain membres du troisième collectif
des sans-papiers appréhendé mardi lors
d'un coup de force contre le centre
d'accueil des étrangers
dix personnes d'origine chinoise sont
toujours en rétention et seront jugés en
appel samedi matin depuis hier soir les
trois quarts du groupe défilent devant
le juge délégué en vue d'une reconduite
à la frontière pour vice de forme
quatre ont déjà été relaxé concernant
huit autres personnes d'origine kurde de
son passé en correctionnelle et ont fait
appel
les autres restent toujours en garde à
vue prolongée à la disposition de la
huitième section du parquet des
différences de traitements dénoncés par
la défense c'est le soin
l'inorganisation des services de la
préfecture soit la volonté délibérée de
finalement de diviser une certaine
défense qui s'est mis en place pour les
sans papiers pour simplifier en plus des
procédures d'appel samedi le tribunal
administratif se prononcera sur les
recours d'arrêt de reconduite à la
frontière